Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
Some of you may have spotted
the big Scarlet Witch
Easter Eggs hidden in the Loki episode 1
One Post-Credits scene and it looks like
it's just the start of Marvel
teasing her return before Avengers
Kang Dynasty.
They already confirmed their
Bring Your bag.
But now we finally started to see more
evidence inside actual Marvel episodes.
What's your storyline for Wanda?
Do you want Well, honestly,
if I were to tell you
exactly what I would one, I think I would
maybe be spoiling something
because
Kevin Feige genuinely asks us
what we want to do with the character,
and then he does it.
So I think what?
I don't know if I can share,
but I just want to come back.
It's one thing for Elizabeth Olsen
and Marvel to say that she's coming back
after a little break
in asking Kevin Feige to do more X-Men stuff.
But it is a totally different level
when you actually start seeing Easter eggs
for her in other Marvel projects.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
We're doing a giveaway for Loki Blu rays.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscribe
and let me know which other series
you want to see.
Loki Season two Crossover with.
We know it's crossing over with Deadpool 3
Like it directly sets that movie up.
It's setting up what's happening
in Avengers Kang Dynasty, Secret Wars.
So there's already a lot of stuff that is
meant to be connected to and help set up.
But you may have seen.
A lot of people
thought that Elizabeth Olsen
had been fired by Marvel
because she was taking a break.
I did a funny video about it a while ago,
like why would Marvel ever fire
Elizabeth Olsen
That would be like the dumbest thing
they could possibly do.
as you can see, she wants to come back
like there's a bunch of ideas
that she has, mostly X-Men related stuff,
but she also wants to take a short break
from only doing Marvel stuff.
So there was never a question about her
eventually coming back.
whispering the words No more attacks
but at least up
until this recent episode of Loki,
it had been all talk, no action.
Then, during Loki season two, episode one,
if you paused and went through
that new end credits scene with hundreds
of details, there's literally hundreds
and hundreds of Easter eggs here, but
the sticky notes are full of Easter eggs
for a ton of completely different things
you might have spotted the big Scarlet
Witch Easter eggs.
It's sort of like
finding a needle in a haystack
of all these many, many Easter eggs.
so fast forward to the credits.
Zoom in and hands.
There are a couple
these
during different parts of the credits,
but the first one here talks about Scarlet
Witch's chaos.
Magic is as Hex moment with an arrow
next to it.
the rest of the note is questioning
the truth behind the monster.
What does it represent?
Because it's questioning if this monster
is connected to Scarlet Witch,
that would imply that the TVA is actively
monitoring Scarlet
Witch across the multiverse right now,
meaning that she would have to be alive
using her chaos.
Magic powers, the TVA monitors everything
in every universe across the multiverse.
They use Miss Minutes
to process the sheer amount of data
like she is hypertext created by Kang
He's from the 30th century.
that acts like the multiverse is greatest
most sinister supercomputer.
Just watch.
sifting through all this data
coming from all these different universes,
you also have the TVA itself,
which is like the size of Manhattan,
full of people like that, many people
all dedicated
to just processing all this information
from different universes.
know the specific monster
that they're referencing
in this Scarlet Witch
note might be alive still,
because episode one is meant to take place
directly after the events of season
one, Episode 6
So by this point, Loki's filled everyone
in on a life he who remains the truth
about the void planet.
What really happens
to everything that they prune
and you look below this too,
there's also a sticky note right here
below the Scarlet Witch note
that references
the boy betrayed in the tower Keeper.
The tower keeper is clearly
he who remains.
I think what's going on with this board
of the hundreds of sticky notes
in hundreds of Easter Eggs, is it it's
meant to be mobius notes, because later
when it shows all the open case files
with all the pictures,
the only main character
not depicted in the case files is Mobius.
so all these different end credits
scenes, these different areas
are meant to be Mobius going for Sherlock,
trying to figure out what's going on
at the beginning of season two.
Like there are a bunch of big mysteries
that they introduce,
but there's also a bunch of mysteries
left over from the end of season one.
there's also another Post-it note
above the Scarlet Witch note
that says The Secret
of the Dark Mountains.
That would be Mount Wundagore where
the main 616 Scarlet Witch disappeared.
Now I say disappeared
because we know that she didn't die.
There was a flash of chaos.
Magic Energy as Chthon's Darkhold
Temple Crash down around her.
But nobody in the Marvel Universe equals
no death.
Now, the note also says
Yorzen's Betrayal.
There's no Yorzen in Marvel Comics.
But that could be a character
that they created for the Loki series,
just for this particular mystery
that he's investigating.
in Mobius wondering if what Scarlet Witch
did during Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness
in her disappearance, her chaos
magic might have something to do
with the multiverse starting to break down
at the beginning of Loki Season 2.
The actual timeline itself
is starting to collapse, that would mean
all of reality also starts to collapse
like R.I.P.
the entire multiverse
the next big Scarlet Witch Easter
egg is a little bit later in the credits.
So fast forward a little bit more zoom
and enhance on top of this report
about an apocalypse
event is the same diagram
that's on the wall,
the Darkhold Temple in Doctor Strange 2.
Now there are a lot of designs
and symbols in the Darkhold Temple
that show up in other Marvel movies too.
most of these symbols are celestial design
symbols that you see in the Eternals
movie, like the design language
of the Celestials just in general,
that's then trying
to connect everything on a cosmic level
across the Marvel multiverse,
basically connecting a line
between Scarlet Witch, her Chaos, Magic,
the Celestials, and everything
that's happening across every universe.
in that gets into Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty, Secret Wars, making
Scarlet Witch a much more central figure
in those next Avengers movies.
Now she was a major
part of the plot in Avengers Infinity War,
but not quite as much in Endgame.
Like she was a big part of an endgame.
He had a couple of big moments,
but she was a bigger character
in Infinity War.
they used a lot of that plot with Vision
in the Mind Stone to drive her story
forward through Wandavision in now
a lot of these Loki Easter eggs
Doctor strange to the Darkhold Temple,
all this chaos magic backstory,
celestial cosmic stuff is setting her up
as a much more central character
in the future of the MCU.
The Apocalypse event behind the Chaos
Magic Celestial Symbol here
probably has something to do
with the events of Doctor Strange 2
because remember, the TVA will be
monitoring everything in every universe.
So they would have been watching
what happened during Doctor Strange two
The real big connection between
what happened during that movie in the TVA
are the incursions themselves
during Doctor Strange 2
that was that Illuminati teaser
with Reed Richards Professor X warning
Doctor Strange about incursions.
basically said everything
that he and Scarlet Witch
were doing messing with the multiverse
was causing more of them,
and then they teased it again
at the end of the film
like you caused another incursion.
an incursion
is like the highest level
of an apocalypse event when two universes
collide with each other,
destroying one or both of them.
That's also what happened during the first
King Multiverse war with timelines
going to war with each other,
the different kings
trying to erase each other's timelines.
the only reason in Doctor Strange 2
that Scarlet Witch got off the hook
on a lot of that in Doctor Strange
took most of the blame for the incursions
was because they thought
now they thought incorrectly that she died
which we know she did not in also Doctor
strange his variants particularly Doctor
Strange Supreme the Illuminati doctor
strange in the 838 universe
had both actively done
terrible things to the multiverse
for different reasons and been caught red
handed like they did it on purpose.
616 Doctor Strange was just trying
to chase down Scarlet Witch and stop her
and that's why he accidentally started
causing incursions.
He wasn't purposely
trying to cause incursions.
Let me know if you think you've spotted
any other Scarlet Witch
references on Loki
There was that hex seen during season
one where the events of the Loki finale
lined up perfectly with Scarlet Witch
coming fully into her chaos.
Magic the Loki showrunner claimed that
that was meant to be a total coincidence.
They weren't trying to take the Loki
finale that far, and I believe her,
I don't think she was lying.
But Marvel has been known
to canonize fan theories after the fact,
especially if they're cool fan theories
case in point,
the biggest one I can think of off
the top of my head was the Spider-Man
theory going back to Iron Man.
So Tom Holland
was responding to a fan theory
when he said this, so it predates him.
But when he and Kevin Borghi were doing
press interviews for Spider-Man
homecoming, Tom Holland said that
he thought a young boy in Iron Man two
wearing the Iron Man mask at the Stark
Expo was a young Peter Parker.
in the ideas it was meant to show
that he always admired.
Iron Man looked up to him and it helped
explain their closer relationship.
In present
day Kevin Feige liked the theory
so much that he said, bam, that's awesome.
It's Canon
He made a cannon on the spot when.
In reality, when they filmed
that original scene in Iron Man two years
before that, Jon Favreau had no intention
of that being young Spider-Man.
in fact, the kid
playing that character in the scene
was Jon Favreau's son in real life.
so literally possible
that Marvel can take a fan theory
like this Wandavision Loki connection
and turn it into a bigger thing
in the future, particularly
if it's a cool Easter egg.
Now, as for Scarlet Witch
actually coming back,
like coming back on screen in a big way,
there were reports
she was going to have some kind of cameo
or be referenced
in some way during the Agatha
Darkhold Diaries show next year.
They're releasing it around this time.
Next year is a show all about the witches.
The witches Road.
What happened with Agatha
after Wandavision
and her son Billy, coming back.
that's who Joe Locke is playing.
So it makes sense
that they would reference
Scarlet Witch in some way
during that series.
and unless she shows up in like a random
movie post-credits
scene for some upcoming movie,
I believe the first time
we're meant to actually see her come
back is in Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty.
I believe we're also supposed
to see a version of Scarlet Witch
during X-Men 97, Season 1 and
What If Season 2. Elizabeth Olsen
does The voice for What If
But the X-Men 97 characters
are like literally the ones from X-Men
animated Series.
It's like season 6 of that show.
so all that stuff is taking place
in another universe.
I don't know if Elizabeth Olsen
would voice that version of Scarlet Witch
or maybe like something
completely different
and just another version of Scarlet Witch.
but all the X-Men
97 episodes are supposed to release
right up to the Echo series in January
or February
I'll be doing videos for everything,
so do not worry,
there's a bunch of really big stuff
coming up.
my full Loki Season 2 Episode 2 Video
will post Friday after they release it.
Be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Congratulations Jeff McNally
You're the giveaway winner
from my last big Loki video
Please email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details
click here for my Loki Season 2
Episode 2 Video onto the link
As soon as I post that and click here
for my full Loki season 2 Episode 1 Video
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one1